[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv 78 bonjour
patrice bonjour
c'est bien moi nous allons parler de
politique nous allons parler de
l'engagement est des jeunes aujourd'hui
alors que les scrutins présidentiel
législatif approche les moins de 24 ans
semble de moins en moins intéressés par
la politique nous avons voulu donner la
parole à plusieurs d'entre eux et pour
qu'il défende aussi un peu leurs idées
et on va aller présenter tout de suite
on va commencer par le doyen
c'est le 28 ans yvette mais vous êtes
vous êtes membres de al air vous êtes
adjoint au maire de la verrière donc
engagé politiquement tout élu un
wandrille de kerpel alors vous êtes
benjamin vous avez 20 ans c'est tout cet
étudiant en droit vous avez été vous
êtes toujours plus ou moins bon goût de
l air mais vous avez rejoint surtout
génération z zegna eric zemmour un effet
mix deltour bonjour vous avez 25 ans
vous êtes co animateur du comité local
lrm de versailles et membre des jeunes
avec mc ren 1 et vous êtes là engagé
très fortement toute attente une
peut-être future campagne s'est passé se
trouvait encore hier suspense terrible
et quentin des mers bonjour vous avez 22
ans vous êtes membre du parti communiste
et vous êtes vous aussi lui vous êtes
puisque vous êtes vous êtes conseiller
municipal de wii en cours un ça va alors
c'est vrai que oui le fait de dire le
problème de l'engagement et des jeunes
il est un peu complexe il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'engagement dans les partis
politiques et des engagements sur des
cous souvent parce qu'ils ne sont pas
engagés dans des partis politiques ne
sont pas du tout engagé mais c'est des
engagements un peu différent peut-être
un peu de un peu de de défiance
vis-à-vis de la politique proprement
dite mais peut-être pour vous
recommencez par vos témoignages
qu'est-ce qui vous vous a fait vous
engager en politique on peut commencer
par vous n'arrivez être mais alors moi
je me suis engagé en politique parce que
j'en avais marre de critiquer je voulais
faire je voulais agir et vous avez
d'ailleurs c'est assez complexe étaient
43 ans de communisme donc quand on est
arrivé il était très bien installés tant
et si bien que la ville était morte
c'est une ville dortoir et plus rien
donc on pourrait réagir
j'ai sorti mon vivant
et plus facilement s'est pas pressé et
du coup c'est là où moi j'ai eu vraiment
envie de m'engager j'ai commencé à l'âge
de 18 19 ans j'étais à lui ni pour vous
dire à l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines ces syndicats étudiants
et puis il ya un deuxième point c'est
aussi très culturelle dans ma famille
vous savez non c'est très bien ce qu'est
ce que justement il ya des transmissions
comme ça bien sûr d'une famille de
droite on est une famille de droite vous
savez moi mes parents ils viennent du
cambodge
donc quand on est arrivés en france nous
tout de suite on c'est assimilé tout de
suite pour nous la france était notre
pays sans renier nos origines évidemment
et comme disait romain gary j'ai pas une
seule goutte de sang français mais la
france coule dans mes veines dit c'était
ma façon à moi en tout cas pourquoi je
faisais de la politique fans la
politique c'était de rendre ce que la
france pas donner une éducation un
patrimoine culturel devenir pleinement
français en pleinement français et ça
c'était de base et pour moi en plus deux
arguments c'était compliqué d'être
communiste ce que vous savez au cambodge
avec paul point c'était un peu compliqué
bon voilà pourquoi je me suis engagé
pour répondre à la question de me frites
sur le désintérêt alors je dirais
politique
déjà moi j'avais fait en mémoire quand
j'étais étudiant sur la confiance
politique et la création d'entreprise et
il y avait une étude qui m'avait marqué
qui encore aujourd'hui valable c'est
l'étude du cevipof cv centre de
descendre d'études de sciences po
sciences po exactement et qu'est ce
qu'elle dit cette étude elle dit qu'en
fait la confiance politique chez par
exemple les présidentielles où les
députés elle est à peu près entre 28 et
30 % et vous savez combien aller pour
les mères elles beaucoup plus forte plus
de 60% des capsules pourquoi deux
fonctions enfin il ya les conseillers
départementaux si ces objecteurs mien et
les autres s'est terré pas exactement
battre et c'est ont fait le lot elle et
moi d'abord je voulais agir localement
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes
ils se sentent de moins en moins
représentées et on peut comprendre aussi
les pompes tout un tas de raisons et
l'engagement politique passe par la
compréhension de la vie politique donc
toutes choses égales par ailleurs qu'on
n'a pas de connaissances politiques on
n'a pas d'intérêt et surtout qu'on n'a
pas confiance bon faiblit donc c'est ça
votre le solde de votre engagement
peut-être passer tout de suite à deux
autres élus
juste pour répondre et aussi sur ce qui
a été dit vous êtes une famille de
droite engagé à droite est ce que
c'était le cas aussi lâchez vous du coup
de l'autre côté à gauche alors moi c'est
une famille où j'ai apporté la politique
en m'engageant en politique le premier
militant politique de ma famille
j'atterris à 15 ans au parti communiste
et moi c'est vraiment la question de
l'héritage historique aussi pour la
france aussi levé du communisme qui est
quand même depuis les congés payés même
toutes les luttes ouvrières dans le
passé et qui font enfin je suis
extrêmement conscient de tous les
services publics on a de tout la qualité
du travail qu'on peut avoir en france
était de vie qu'on peut avoir ce qui a
été la sq étaient là on l'a gagné en
fait on s'est battu pour l'avoir et j'ai
voulu m'inscrire dans ce dans ce combat
là dans ce travail là
dd jaurès des torres décroise à des
marchés c'est peut être tout est de
socialisme enfin le ps plutôt que le
paisible pourquoi parce que le
communisme il ya aussi ce que ce que ce
que je disais à l'instant il ya aussi
une histoire parfois qui est un peu
tragique vous avez 22 ans le communisme
à 22 ans ça signifie quoi
je pense que justement j'ai eu la chance
de ne pas connaître les pays de l'est
c'est donc tout le problème de
l'effondrement des
même si je dois aussi répondre sur le
cambodge en disant que c'est le vietnam
communiste qui habille forte mer rouge
c'est pas les pays occidentaux qui sont
venus intervenir pour libérer les
cambodgiens du joug des bijoux de polpot
le communisme c'est ça avant tout de
leur vie d'émanciper les autres c'est en
vue de travailler à faire grandir
l'humanité
j'aurais pu être socialiste dans le pays
il ya aussi l'héritage culturel en
france que vous ayez des figures par
exemple du communisme qui vous ont
inspiré ses pas georges marchais même
même historiquement déjà les sépare la
lecture déjà je suis devenu communiste
donc c'est en lisant marxisant aussi
lénine et les autres grands grands qui
écrivent bien et qui qui savent aussi
bien décortiquer le monde qui n'a pas
tant changé que ça dansait dans les
grandes structures qui font qu'ils font
le monde dans l'exploitation qui domine
ce monde et donc j'étais marqué par tous
ces figures la cua s'il a changé des
choses et ça va ça va de lénine aussi
après pour ses tentatives en russie à
sankara aussi au burkina faso dans sa
lutte contre la police mais français il
ya deux à l'étranger alors il ya
l'étranger dont il ya aussi bien au
silence et au reste je ne sais pas quand
il risque aussi pour pour son travail
ambroise croizat pour la secrète et
social je pourrais en citer beaucoup les
premières femmes élues et député à
l'assemblée nationale qui était
majoritairement communiste c'est ça va
autant dans des grandes figures comme la
petite figure du militant qui dans son
entreprise se mobilisent moi je pense un
petit peu à toutes ces ouvrières et
ouvriers à qui on a toujours renié le
droit d'exister qui par le parti
communiste ont pu se développer ont pu
grandir et prendre une place devenir élu
député maire combien de mères en france
on était ouvrier et bas quasiment tous
été communiste donc c'est la capacité
d'un parti la structure collective de
permettre à l'individu de s'émanciper de
tout ce qui le bloque au niveau
individuel pour devenir ensuite pour
grandir et faire avancer sa classe va
faire avancer les gens qui lui ressemble
et peut-être conseil municipal s'engage
est aussi politiquement aller devant les
électeurs sont importantes oui et
justement j'ai une délégation sur
l'observatoire de l'habitat sur les 50%
de hlm qu'on assure guy en cours et
c'est un vrai combat pour nous en en
région parisienne attentive de paris
d'avoir beaucoup de logements sociaux de
permettre à tout le monde de vivre de
vivre projet paris je rappelle encore
une fois 70 % des franciliens sont
éligibles au logement social c'est une
vraie bataille pour nous de dire que
toutes les classes tout le monde à
droite vit dans une belle ville comme
nuit en cours et donc de livres à des
prix pas trop élevé et donc en dehors du
marché on pourrait dire la campagne est
terminée en juin
félix un félix benneteau oui alors moi
dans la famille pas d'engagement
politique particulier avant le mien moi
mon engagement il s'est créé à l'époque
en 2017 au entre le premier et le second
tour des élections présidentielles
un peu comme cette génération 2002 qui
s'était réveillée au second tour entre
jacques chirac et jean marie le pen moi
j'ai trouvé qu'on avait un vrai un vrai
problème or en termes de
représentativité comment on en était
arrivé à ce que la droite et la gauche
s'effondre dès le premier tour et que ce
soit l'extrême droite qui reviennent au
devant de la scène alors qu'elle s'était
effacé un peu depuis 2002 on sentait
qu'elle remontait mais elle n'était plus
au même niveau que à cette époque là et
j'ai adhéré à la figure d' emmanuel
macron puisqu'elle représentait à la
fois ce que je pouvais apprécié disons
chez le parti des républicains sur la
politique économique est à la fois les
luttes sociales et l'avancé en terme de
droit qui a été aussi un marqueur du
quinquennat qu'on est en train de
terminer avec avec emmanuel macron est
donc ce premier engagement il était
plutôt local mois à partir de 2017 à
versailles et et dans les yvelines à la
fois côté la république en marché et
côté des jeunes avec macron est
aujourd'hui comme vous le disiez patrice
j'ai passé le deuxième cas pour 2022 et
donc je m'engage un peu plus globalement
en ayant mis fin à certaines de mes
autres activités pour pouvoir
complètement m'engager à la fois sur le
terrain et puis pour aider aussi
d'autres territoires à avancer et à
travailler sur une campagne qui devrait
arriver quand c'est un autre je sentais
la question arrivait mais n'en ont parlé
mais
j'organisais enfin entre les deux tours
de 2017 macron c est la droite et la
gauche vous étiez à l'origine tout senti
plus plus une sensibilité plutôt à
gauche plutôt à droite je dirais que
c'est à la fois et la droite et la
gauche et en même temps quand on regarde
bien là en même temps à la fois dans les
voiles après ça paraît un peu un peu
cliché maintenant mais dans l'est dans
les figures qu'il a réussi à rallier et
peut-être dans d'autres qui arriveront
c'est en même temps ni la droite ni la
gauche avez-vous puisqu'on a réussi à
l'été votre sensibilité leur église un
avis
centriste voilà plus plutôt plutôt à
droite plutôt centre-droit sur devait
aujourd'hui nommé à un parti qui s'en
rapprocherait ça serait plutôt un parti
comme agir de centre droit que les mêmes
les républicains qui aujourd'hui sont
pour ma part un petit peu trop à droite
c'est du riz soutien politique voilà
franck riester on a un petit peu d'aidé
contre exemple sur le plateau parce que
l'institut montaigne qui a mené une
enquête auprès de 8000 et jeunes de 18 à
24 ans et on va faire réagir au début
mais c'est juste pour compléter ce que
vous disiez puisque c'est cette étude
qui est plutôt intéressante et qui
compare aussi à l'engagement des parents
et des grands parents parlent de
désaffiliation politique pour les 18 24
ans plus de la moitié ne savent pas dire
si son droite ou de gauche là
aujourd'hui on a plutôt l'inversé
d'ailleurs on va poser maintenant la
question pour vous vous saviez vous
étiez qu'il est drôle c'est qu'il est
quelque part cette droite alors déjà moi
je dis alors pourquoi est ce que je me
suis engagé en politique moi je me suis
engagé en politique déjà je suis
toujours un peu engagés ou scouts à la
réserve sous le drapeau parce que mon
pays ben j'ai envie de me défendre et et
j'ai envie de le protéger et ensuite en
politique pourquoi parce que moi je me
veux m'engager d'abord au service du
bien commun et nos politiques ont
beaucoup délaissé cette histoire du bien
commun parce qu'en fait finalement on a
matraqué on a aussi matraque et aux
jeunes et c'est que finalement les
politiques n'étaient que des
opportunistes qui ne servaient que leurs
propres intérêts et finalement promettez
de grandes choses recopa levé n'agissez
pas derrière et donc moi j'ai envie de
changer les choses parce que moi je me
dis et en fait on a une jeunesse qui est
là qu on dit qu'elle est endormi et
finalement qui est mobilisable on voit
généralement ces dons à dix mille jeunes
à peine deux mois qu'ils sont mobilisés
parce que derrière il ya une
personnalité qui acquit un idéal et qui
apporte quelque chose est une qui
portent des convictions au fait qu'on a
beaucoup délaissé ces importantes
figures comme ça un peu tutélaire vaincu
ou là sur l'incarnation est important
d'autant plus la richesse des idées une
belle fidélité je vais dire des recettes
de ces personnalités il ya des idées à
tenir et les voilà nous le point commun
entre tous les militants et les
adhérents en reconquête c'est la survie
de notre civilisation et puis l'amour
deux pays et donc et booder bande à eric
zemmour qui est qui qui se présente aux
élections présidentielles on va le
porter jusqu'à l'elysée et on a aussi
cette intrigue notre président des
jeunes républicains qui est très bon
vous voyez partout qui nous reste à
entendre les médias une vraie star chez
les jeunes ben tout simplement parce
qu'il incarne jeunesse qui n'étaient pas
entendus et donc ils ouvrent vous avez
fait le choix de l'engagement en
politique est ce que d'autres jeunes
s'engagerait en politique on fait juste
une courte pause micro-trottoir que nous
avons réalisés dans les rues de saint
quentin en yvelines dans les rues du
département aussi vous engageriez vous
en politique au sein d'un parti je l' ai
déjà fait white-ra prend encore pour
faire pareil pour faire entendre ma voix
les jeunes on n'est jamais entendue sur
le plan de la politique avec des vrais
jeunes et pas des gens sortis d'écoles
de commerce ou des fils à papa des fils
d'avocat des fils de médecin je pense si
jamais j'ai conservé au parti oui je
penserai prêt à m'engager opposition
politique mais dit et je sais pas
vraiment que je sois convaincu mais je
pourrais oui je pense qu'ils pourraient
participer afin tracts et je me suis
convaincu que je pense que je pourrais
je me sens pas prête et pas capable en
tout cas mais peut-être derrière enfin
on appuie oui mais en tout cas pas
devant le public objectivement non pas
du tout
parce que j'aime pas donner mon avis je
trouve que personnellement je garde mon
avis pour moi et si on me demande mon
avis je le donne je pense que
l'engagement il peut se faire très bien
ailleurs dans un parti je sais pas mais
je pense que la politique elle peut se
faire beaucoup ailleurs dans les
mouvements sociaux
dans des associations
des choses comme ça pour ce micro
trottoir réalisé à saint quentin en
yvelines devant l'université pour être
précis
puisque vous êtes tous s'engagent si
vous avez des copains qui le saut qu'ils
sont pas est ce que vous êtes vous
apparaissez comme des sortes d'oiseaux
rares
ces deux évasions dagan s'engage c'est
comme tout engagement comme langage on
peut se faire des ennemis ou parfois on
peut reconnaître qu'ils sont les vrais
amis et c'est vrai mauvaise que vous
avez des potes qui vous dirai à mes 40
18 pourquoi tu veux ça est ce que vous
avez perdu des postes pourquoi tu fais
ça est ce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'utile et moi je le redis toute
façon j'ai jamais vu des personnes
normales faire des choses
exceptionnelles notamment de données je
dois vous est donc on a l'impression
d'être un peu
mais en tout cas il ya un truc que je
viens d'entendre là qui me chagrine
c'est oui c'est toujours les fils
d'avocat mais pas du tout s'était joué
j'ai envie de vous dire que c'est laid
aux jeunes le mouvement fera d'ailleurs
son mandat en vrai en plus ce qu'il faut
se dire c'est qu'un moment donné faut
pas être dans l'assistanat d'attendre
que ça tombe du ciel si tu as envie de
te battre pour ton pays de bottes pour
ta commune qui va tu mobilise si t'as
pas envie d'avoir envie mais faut pas
s'en plaindre moi je suis comme ça en
tout cas c'est mes valeurs c'est à dire
que si vous voyez qu'il ya un problème
dans votre entreprise dans votre famille
vous agissez mais si paris pour la vie
politique et pour le pays
le regard des autres la campagne
ce qu'il trouve qu après des études ce
fait un minimum de sociologie je sais
pas dans nos études monsieur est élu à
la verrière il pense qu'il sait que les
gens qui vivent au bois de l'étang par
exemple n'ont pas les mêmes facilités à
s'engager en politique que des gens qui
viennent même du village de l'albère
guerre ou qui viennent ou qui viennent
d'ailleurs moi je pense que ce qu'il a
dit est très très important et on a
besoin
des gens étaient venus voir que des gens
ou de voir que des gens individuellement
c'est tellement facile de s'engager en
politique je pense qu'on a aussi un
bagage culturel a un bagage social qui
fait que c'est plus facile de s'engager
moi mes parents par le biais ils ont
fait des études donc même s'ils font pas
de politique ils m'ont toujours appris à
bien me comporter comme ça enfin oui moi
je moi je viens pas d'un milieu pro
libraire dès le départ donc et je
comprends que oui c'est plus compliqué
et c'est ça qu'il faut les structures il
faut les syndicats et les partis pour
accompagner pour accompagner les gens
aujourd'hui il n'y a quasiment aucun
député qui est ouvrier ou employé alors
que ces gens là ils pèsent un poids
énorme à société et donc ça c'est quand
même un scam un problème c'est qu'elle a
un problème que les gens soient pas
représentés et ça veut dire qu'il faut
du coup des structures des corps
intermédiaires qui structure le pays qui
structure la débarque comme les pilotes
qui font ressortir des gens c'est le
travail qu'on essaie de faire aussi au
parti communiste c'était un travail
individuel il faut que tu le sais que
c'est pas vrai qu'un médecin connaît la
vie d'un ouvrier à un médecin il a aussi
ses problèmes et souvent ils y voient
alors ils envoient oui c'est vrai mais
oui mais moi aussi je connais mes
cinquièmes beaucoup
salvador allende je suis et je peux dire
que quand on est dans ce canton quand on
ne fait pas de politique la politique
nous rattrape et donc quand on veut pas
s'engager et qu' il ya des choses qui
nous plaisent pas bon on peut pas s'en
plaindre non plus et donc moi je pense
que tout peut s'engager en politique
tout ne peut s'engager parce qu'il
regarde vos copains a le regard de mes
z'amis bois ils sont très contents que
je m'engage en politique qui me
soutiennent ils sont au courant de
l'actualité et puis ça les hanter les
salles et ça les fait s'intéresser à la
politique et vous avez déçus des fautes
qu'ils sont
qui ont déjà dit j'ai des amis à la fac
qui ont des idées complètement
différentes des miennes mais ils sont
aussi contents de voir que quelqu'un
s'engage à permettre c'est tellement
rare maintenant chez les jeunes de
s'engager réellement hâte de mettre
finalement sa personne et son temps pour
la politique et enfin voir mon cas je
soutiens avec zéro ce qui qui sont qui
n'ont pas les idées que moi etc il va
finalement ils sont ils marquent plutôt
sur la figure d'eric zemmour au lieu de
trouver que j'avais le sens de l'humour
bah oui là non non on est au delà de
l'autodérision et au sort pas félix je
pense que sur la question est ce qu'on
perd des amis quand on a un engagement
politique et qui n'ont pas le même en
fait on je rejoins d'arriva ton père des
gens qui étaient pas vraiment des amis
es et les autres pays restent même si on
a des idées très opposés et je pense
qu'en plus ça rattrape souvent dans les
discussions même des discussions très
amicale sur un sujet on va dire lambda
on il ya toujours quelque chose qui sort
de la politique d'autant plus avec des
périodes électorales là qui s'enchaînent
que ce soit au niveau des municipales
des régionales où maintenant des
présidentielles législatives il ya
toujours un sujet qui touche et où on
raccorde et pays'' a c'est vrai que si
j'étais engagé je pourrais faire changer
telle chose pour mon département nous
arrive et me convainc pas conques alors
convaincre d'aller voter et de s'engager
où il convaincre de s'engager dans le
même parti des mots dans la même
formation je trouve que c'est compliqué
et puis ces jeux pour fou que c'est
aussi parfois le meilleur moyen quand on
force de casser une amitié si on se dit
bah l'engagement ça peut passer que par
la même structure que la mienne ça peut
passer par plein de choses moi ce qui
m'inquiète plus c'est pas la
représentativité là qui était donné ça
c'est un vrai débat mais c'est les gens
en fait ça commence d'abord par une idée
est-ce que j'en suis capable et on a
commencé à en parler et en fait je pense
que c'est le travail aussi des
organismes de jeunesse dans les partis
politiques de montrer qu'on n'est pas
juste là pour coller rétracter lisez
aussi mais on peut sortir des idées
récemment je vais parler je vais prêcher
pour ma paroisse mais le les jeunes avec
macro ont sorti un livret programmatique
avec des propositions qu'il compte
proposer aux futurs candidats on
l'espère emmanuel macron dès qu'il se
présentera mais c'est aussi une manière
de dire aux jeunes bas on a fait le tour
de toute la france pour faire des petits
ateliers avec eux ils nous ont sortis
des nous ont fait ressortir des
problèmes des thématiques qui touchent
la jeunesse eh bien on sort un livre et
on y va on va le porter qu'est ce que ça
donnera on ne sait pas mais au moins
votre voix a été entendue et chacun peut
se retrouver dans une mesure qui va être
portée ou non ces jeunes qui doivent
avoir aussi l'impression dont toujours
que la politique ne sert à rien je
reviens sur cette un derniers chiffres
de l'institut montaigne sur l' enquête
dont je parlais tout à l'heure il ya
près de la moitié tout de même des
jeunes qui trouvent acceptables ou
compréhensible de s'affronter à des élus
pour protester d'insulter un président
de la république pour les 18 24 ans la
moitié seulement jugent important
d'avoir un gouvernement démocratique
ce qui est particulièrement inquiétant
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui non
seulement la politique ne sert à rien et
en plus la place pas plus forcément par
la démocratie c'est dramatique déficit
de confiance politique on revient au
sujet de la confiance et en plus c'est
dramatique puisque la france ça va on
n'est pas chez les bolchéviques font
elles pas la stasi quoi c'est la france
est un pays démocratique et la
séparation des pouvoirs un moment donné
qu'ils aillent voir en arabie saoudite
qu'ils aillent voir par exemple en corée
du nord
c'est quoi une dictature
je vais vous dire moi je déteste qu'on
critique vraiment mais c'est viscéral je
déteste qu'on critique notre pays en
prétextant qu'il ait des petites au réal
où il ya un gouvernement on y pense mais
c'est dingue et qui je pense ça passe
par la méconnaissance des bénéfices gaza
comment fonctionne la constitution
comment fonctionne honnêtement quand
j'étais la semaine dernière j'ai emmené
des jeunes à l'assemblée nationale avec
mon député philippe benassaya et ont
posé beaucoup aux jeunes savez vous à
quoi ça sert l'assemblée nationale les
jeunes de 15 ans quand même mais ne
savait pas que qui ait siégé à gérer ses
invités c'est gravissime il ya un
problème dans l'éducation dans l
éducation nationale parce que tout
simplement ça fait partie du projet
voici pourquoi mais sûrement pourquoi
votre id ce que déficit de confiance
politique ça vient de quoi d'une
méconnaissance je les dis donc d'une
éducation et l'éducation pardonnez moi
c'est pas que des familles c'est l'état
et je pense que l'état depuis un certain
nombre d'années sur les programmes
scolaires on enseigne de moins en moins
comment fonctionnent les chais où les
gens de la démocratie règlement
mais c'est automatique il ya un danger
que les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui on a
vu la camionnette depuis à la crise et
il est jeune il ya eu une espèce de
starification de certaines personnalités
il des réseaux sociaux qui se sont
affrontés face au gouvernement à
l'époque pour les gilet jaune là on a
les antilles vague c les antilles parce
sanitaire est en fait faut pas oublier
non je pense qu'on est moins touchée
parce qu'on est un peu la génération au
dessus des 15 18 ans mais ils
s'abreuvent énormément avec les réseaux
sociaux et en fait ils n'ont une vision
que parcellaire de ce qui se passe ils
n'entendent souvent que les
contestataires ce quand on regarde les
comptes qui fonctionne bien et qui parle
de politique à part quelques figures qui
vont essayer de rendre ça comment dire
un peu plus pédagogique et je vois que
vous présentez nous parler des lisez
tout à l'heure où de certains à youtube
heures la plupart sur les réseaux
sociaux qui marche très bien en ce
moment tik tok et wigan pour rebondir
puisque vous parlez de l'elysée
effectivement le rêveur sur plateau un
aperçu du site internet elysées dont on
voulait parler un petit peu si une
application un cas a été lancé et qui
permet justement le thunder de la
politique prenne plus de patrice vous
soyez paix
avec le pouce est ce que vous vous y a
des propositions de candidats qui sont
présentés vous prenez vous prenez pas
vous ne savez pas et au final en
fonction de vos réponses et de vos
affinités ben on vous dit quelle serait
votre candidat ça donne des choses des
fois assez surprenante pour avoir testé
un peu l'application et je me suis
retrouvé avec la gauche et la droite
c'est même niveau donc autant hidalgo
valérie pécresse et que emmanuel macron
quasiment donc c'est ce qui n'a pas de
sens mais bon moi c'est un premier pas
vers vers la compréhension et les armes
etc mais bon si on en met à swype et
pour savoir pour qui aller voter c'est
vrai que vous avez raison il ya d'abord
une question d'éducation qu'il faudrait
faut traiter la cause par la conséquence
quoi je reviens à la question posée
wilfrid c'est à dire sur les violences
on l'a vu il y avait des mères il ya eu
des fous est élu 1
ça peut vous arriver savez bien c'est
vous et vous comprenez ça il ya parfois
de la dige désespoir il ya parfois je
comprend au total donc honnêtement comme
nous on est arrivé avec nicolas david
monds mer à la ville de laval et toute
l'équipe on avait fait un nouveau projet
vous savez projet henry obbo des temps
très connu dans les éviers lancement est
évidemment il ya eu des pour il ya eu
des contres il désire destruction de ce
quartier de reconstruction et de
réhabilitation qui permettrait à toute
la verrière de s'en sortir grandie le
problème c'est que à cause de certains
syndicats de gauche ou de partis
politiques de gauche qui essayent de
désinformer sacré de la violence qu'elle
soit physique ou verbale par exemple mon
maire a été caillassé et je voulais
ajouter quelques jongles fried c'était
sur la désacralisation de l'état y
regarder on le voit emmanuel macron il
s'est fait gifler combien de fois ongles
à jeter un oeil sur la tête et puis à
m'hamid y est même parfois une sur deux
n 1 2 qui se met ça passe par quoi ainsi
je pense très honnêtement encore une
fois il ya un manque de transparence
et quand on n'est pas transparent là je
parle vraiment pour le président ne part
ne mettrait pas des données d'élections
mais tout de même c'est que on avait la
clé des gilet jaune il a fui toutes les
fonctions régaliennes toutes ses
missions régaliennes les réformes des
retraites etc on a eu ensuite le
qu'ovide être le co lead qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour ne pas être pour le
deux mâts sont pas une accumulation de
frustrations donc je peux comprendre que
nous qui représentons finalement les
institutions je vais présenter la
commune que parfois on nous prend à
partie c'est à dire que l'on fait qu'on
devient l'élu je pense qu'à un moment
donné ne s'appartient plus on appartient
au genre quant à votre
jeu j'ai envie de répondre hier
soir j'ai travaillé hier je connais bien
m du dessus je connais bien un peu la
situation l'ancienne mairie
je sais que je suis je suis sur
l'habitat et moi ça me gêne un petit peu
quand même on pourrait rappeler qu'aux
élections municipales le quartier balle
étant elle même très majoritairement
voté pour madame dû tuer pas pour la
liste des invités
il est communiste la maire sortante et
on parle quand même dans un angle de
détruit du logement on parle comme à des
gens qui vivent à 30 km de paris encore
une fois qu'ils n'auront pas d'autre
moyen de se reloger qui ont aujourd'hui
des grands logements qui sont les
logements les jo de l'êta encagoulés
d'inepties
les gens ici depuis très longtemps avec
tous les problèmes qu'a à la verrière
aussi du quartier qui enclavées et qui
pris entre deux routes c'est vrai est-ce
que enlever un tiers de un tir va
vraiment changer les choses à part
supprimé du logement à des gens qui
vivent ici depuis très longtemps qu'ils
vont devoir se reconstruire une vie
ailleurs dans des logements très souvent
je suis désolé mais les chartes android
c'est très bien et puis souvent charte
de relogement oui pris sa succession
le quartier le plus paisible où qu'ils
soient c'est pas équipe est le problème
moi je suis je suis je suis je suis pour
qu'on mette du logement social partout
donc est ce que dans le respect dans une
logique où tous les leviers genre de
reléguer le aussi mais c'est toutes les
villes joué le jeu et qu'il ait pas de
ghetto de riches si l'ailé comme le
chesnay versailles par exemple eux ils
produisaient et protides logement social
on pourrait imaginer je suis d'accord
115% gens se sentent un peu trop
peut-être mais tant qu'il ya des
problèmes de logement il ya deux
millions de personnes qui attendent un
logement social
j'arrive pas à voir comment on peut
légitimer le supprimer du logement du
logement et après on pourra discuter de
comment les faits comme levier de
l'agglomération on ne veulent pas
accueillir des populations c'est à dire
sur le sujet oui pourquoi est-ce-que
pourquoi est ce qu on désacralise la
fonction présidentielle mais en fait
simplement parce qu'on a un président
qui fait des roulades dans l'elysée pour
plaire avec fred karato des youtuber
méprise et walt jijel à rouler vers
sinon c'est oui
par le passé ont aussi reçu des
humoristes sont prêtés comme une fois ce
jeu aussi enfin oui m'enfin je suis
désolé mais il faut aussi garder une
certaine distance qu'on est présente la
plus motivée pour briser d'être jupiter
de temps en temps il pour descendre sur
terre mais je suis d'accord il faut
trouver un juste milieu et enfants là
belle excuse président d'être jupitérien
et le pas s'adresser le deuxième but
avant de décider d'être
une deuxième partie où avec peut-être
parfois mais on le reconnaît nous mêmes
un certaine maladresse vous parlez de la
roulade bon est ce que c'était vraiment
une maladresse c'est pas lui qui l'a
réalisé mais un des deux youtuber mais
en fait soit on essaye de s'adresser aux
gens et on est on est trop trop vulgaire
on désacralise la fonction ou alors
quand on essaye de de l'incarner au
maximum qui est possible on devient
jupitérien et on n'est pas ce que c'est
très très loin c'est le point de craquer
pour revenir sur la violence sociale
difficile de
décider de se rapprocher des gens quand
on fait des dîners et que sa femme
jusqu'à 120 mille euros ont été sortis
en vue d'être ça c'est difficile jeudi a
été réparé par des médias et on a bien
il ya bien été montré qu'il n'y avait
pas d'argent public avait été mis sur la
table pour ses dîners c'est des deniers
personnels de la même manière
qu'aujourd'hui quand le président de la
république reçoit des personnes à titre
privé tout est en deniers personnels
n'étaient même pas présents depuis qu'il
est ministre il était miss mais c'est
pas de l'argent n'est pas sortie de
bercy vous regardez le fun shopping
vous entend et juste à vous entendre
discuter je pense qu'on prendrait vos
aînés pour faire un débat de la même
manière on aurait les mêmes discussions
lors qu'est ce qu'ils disent négligé
qu'est ce qui différencie les laines le
fait d'être jeune et de s'engager en
politique si au final c'est pour
reproduire le même genre de débats et de
discussions mais non mais pour revenir
sur la sueur sur la violence on en
parlait tout à l'heure pour quoi il ya
un niveau de violence sur les élus je
pense que c'est parce que à un moment
moi je verrai comment je les analyse et
c'est qu'au moment de la crise et gilet
jaune il ya eu une habitude dans
l'imagerie qui était donné aux français
de montrer de la violence tous les
samedis et parce que les médias avaient
le devoir d'informer mais en fait on a
montré les mêmes images aux gens d'une
violence extrême contre des forces de
l'ordre parfois même contre des
représentants de l'état et des
préfectures qui ont été incendiés et jeu
il ya jeu mais la faute sur personne je
dis juste que quand on montre plusieurs
samedi d'affilée sur des mois et des
mois des images de violence aux gens et
bien chez certaines personnes il ya il
ya une désinhibition qui s'installe et
d'essayer
la faute des médias
il ya eu des torts mais dans la manière
de traiter la violence mais quand un ep
de la violence je pense que il ya encore
une fois un problème un défaut de
beaucoup de partis politiques et des
syndicats ne pas avoir réussi accompagne
aussi cette colère là le but pour moi
d'un corps intermédiaires comme un parti
ou un syndicat c'est les gens sont en
colère et nous ensuite on transmet cette
colère la réponse politique c'est le
rôle des partis politiques et c'est le
rôle des assemblées aussi c'est que si
les gens qui sont en colère aujourd'hui
ne trouve pas de ressort dans l'est dans
les partis politiques et donc du coup ça
finit en explosion violente et c'est
vrai qu'on peut déplorer la violence
même temps il faut aussi la comprendre
il faut aussi voir c'est une réponse
aussi un début de mandat qui était
extrêmement violent pour les gens aussi
les gens ils voient ce premières mesures
on supprime isf ensuite on leur fait on
leur fait les appels on leur fait la loi
travail les gens ils font que perdre ils
vont que par dix mais en fait je me fais
avoir tous les côtés il suffit d'un coup
que l'essence montrent un tout petit peu
pour que l'un d'eux s'appelle d'achat
excellent temps normal les choses si
c'est ce que
l'extrême gauche
caillasser aux abords des meetings
d'eric zemmour parce qu'en fait
finalement il ne peut plus personne
n'allait représente parce que ils ont
ils se sont divisés ils n'ont pas trouvé
de cohérence idéologique et du coup la
seule manière pour eux de s'exprimer
cela les caillasser frappé juste et moi
je trouve ça dingue quand même et il est
violent les violences qu'on a pu voir
que les médias on peut retransmettre en
fait moi je trouve ça dingue il faut
c'est un peu dégueulasse chez moi de le
dire nous ça dégueulasse que qui en fait
finalement le seul moyen d'expression
fait d'une partie de la population ci
dessus
de faire des bayards dorée chez les
hauts de sainte foy j'ai justement
j'avais moi j'ai une question est ce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu ça veut peut-être
partie du désenchantement et peut-être
du moindre engagement des jeunes il ya
une période dorée ce dec 80 sur 110 80
où on avait l'impression que dans une
élection si on votait pour l'un pour
l'autre c'était limité au registre cas
ont voté pour un type de société ou pour
une autre c'est quand même un peu moins
le cas aujourd'hui j'irai si on veut
pécresse ou maquereau friands pas non
plus changé de monde et c est quand même
bien sûr vague zemmour mélenchon c'est
mon 2e des
bébés mais en même temps il ya donc
moins d'enjeu et est pourtant plus de
violence comme si des choix était
terrible comment vous est bein contre
indiqué chez moi je m'en serais qu'il
moins d'enjeux moi je pense que la
france arrive à un point de non retour
est la croisée des chemins et moi je
considère qu'aujourd'hui et cette
élection
eh ben il faut absolument enfin la
france n'a pas dit son dernier mot et
moi je veux remettre la france et je
veux rendre la fierté de france et tous
ces jeunes tous ces jeunes etc moi je
trouve ça dommage que ben moi je sais
rien c'est d'être français aujourd'hui
version des faits aujourd'hui les jeunes
à part nous je pense sur cette table
beaucoup de jeunes ne se sont plus fiers
d'appartenir à la france est beaucoup
beaucoup se disent européen regardez
on est plutôt un pays qui
mais si on regarde les stages y sont
bien plus fiers d'être des trams et ses
quelques doutes c'est quoi être fier
d'être français bombe à l'esclavagé
fierté doit s engager dans nos rangs
s'engager en politique
si on était vraiment fier de peillon
seront engagerait beaucoup plus et moi
je trouve ça donne des trucs aux
etats-unis beaucoup mais je suis allé là
bas tout bas tous les fientes il ya une
absorption qui est encore plus raccord
ville ça sera du thé dans les armées ton
rêve tout jeunes américains rêvent
d'être humains être fiers des avancées
c'est s'engager dans l'armée pas
forcément non c'est ce qu' il ya
plusieurs manières
parce que je sais manière de s'engager
et l'armée fait partie aussi aux etats
unis c'est comme ça que ça se produit
moi je trouve que la france mérite
beaucoup mieux que des guerres de
chapelles que la cathédrale s'effondrer
d'accord je pense qu'il faut les médias
ont encore une fois ont joué un rôle
c'est assez néfaste notamment je pense à
seignosse par exemple moi je pense que
enfin tous les jeunes et je ne connais
personne qui n'est pas que ce soit pas
fier d'être français en plus des
délégations j'aimerais beaucoup de gens
dans la chesnaie mes autres les gens
sont fiers d'être ce qu'ils sont ils
sont fiers de vous êtes sur les 15-25 si
on lors de poser la question notamment
sur les ailes et la loi religieuse on
leur pose la question entre la mort
française et la loi de votre religion
qu'elle est peu important vous savez ce
qu'ils répondent la dose la religion
donc question très simple
pensez vraiment de notre pays les jeunes
ils sont tous faire des français et de
la france sur un plateau télé jeudi que
globalement globalement si l'effet
défense
ghosn n'a pas réussi à dire vive la
france et la france ont soumis ça se
rapproche de la france et celui
vous prenez des personnalités
individuelles comme ça enfin non diviser
la france était menacée
pour c'est pas mon groupe je suis pas
responsable donc si vous la verrez la
différence on a deux groupes différents
corpus idéologique
décidé de fuir je vois parti communiste
que de la france vers foncé 2000 ans
d'histoire c'est pas karl marx il n'y a
pas dit ça
c'est quand même emilie 9 1 c'est une
méconnaissance historique de l'histoire
du mouvement ouvrier français c'est
quand même assez incroyable évidemment
le drapeau rouge a toujours été de
l'otan pour plus blanc rouge mais nous
on n'est pas des nationalistes on aime
la france comme on aime la france mais
elle est aussi accueillir et
vous avez un candidat pour le groupe qui
après qu'il a fait venir nous reprocher
qu'on n'aimerait pas la france et là je
trouve mais non je dis juste que le les
problèmes que des banderilles pour le
coup j'ai peut-être pas tort c'est que
au niveau de la jeunesse il ya un
sentiment de fierté française et de momo
présente d'où le désengagement politique
d'où le désintérêt politique c'est tout
ce qu'on me dit où tout dépendre mais il
pourrait y avoir la fierté d'être
novatrice d'un système l'europe l'union
européenne est un système est évidemment
qui garantit la paix nos échanges
économiques c'est un système la présente
une délation exactement la france est
une nation c'est des frontières c'est
une histoire c'est tout tout est
différent la culture exactement et comme
disait paul valéry lapointe c'est quoi
j'appelle toute terre française celle
qu'a été christianisée romanisée sous la
discipline des grecs paul valéry ça
c'est l'identité de la france est
aujourd'hui cette identité là elle a été
altéré par plusieurs choses je veux vous
donner l'exemple moi je donne un exemple
si on prend par exemple le sujet par
valérie pécresse là c'est donc alléger
sur l'immigration de masse aujourd'hui
qu'on voit l'immigration de l'époque de
mes parents ont fui et donc la guerre
réfugiés politiques nous arrivons en
france on embrasse la culture de la
france et
ono s'adapte à la culture française dans
les années 80 90 il ya eu le savez
l'europe le regroupement familial etc et
c'est un peu venez comme vous êtes 75
venez comme vous êtes du coup c'est à
dire que
l'assimilation est passé à de
l'intégration c'est toute la nuit on
sait là c'est à dire que moi et moi pas
aux personnes qui viennent dans notre
territoire et parce que le raid est de
renier leurs origines peux-tu te regarde
et je suis très fier d'être cambodgien
d'origine mais je reste avant tout
français et il ya une fois deux mois le
livre de marc bloch d'élise est très bon
marguelov disait je ne revendique mes
origines que face d'un antisémite la
france j'y suis né j'y vais aux sources
de sa culture je ne peux respirer bien
que sous son ciel et j'essaye
aujourd'hui de la défendre de mon mieux
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui pensent comme
moi là aujourd'hui très peu en tout cas
mais voilà après bon on va pas aborder
ce n'est pas parce qu'il est un peu
compliqué celui de la civilisation elle
se dilate et l'intégration mais doivent
avoir plusieurs formes d'intégration
dans un dans une nation enfin cette
simulation non mais ils semblent faits
de que certains jeunes ne se disent pas
fier d'être français ça c'est un il faut
prendre le problème moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est de voir qu'une partie
de la classe politique aujourd'hui
plutôt que de travailler sur des
solutions qui
on va pas aimer le mot de l'autre côté
de la phrase mais permettrait d'intégrer
tout le monde et de les amener vers
l'assimilation certes mais d'abord de
les intégrer et de l'esap d amener à
faire à faire corps avec avec la société
en fait la plupart des candidats surtout
à droite excusez moi messieurs propres
propose de l'exclusion on est sur un
programme qui exclut plus qu'il qu'il
inclut et ses parents et ce n'est pas en
stigmatisant il faut il faut poser le
problème il faut le faux le définir il
faut le il faut trouver des manières
d'accompagner les gens et et de suivre
cette évolution pour la facilité et pour
leur donner envie d'être français et de
le revendiquer mais c'est pas en
stigmatisant et en et en disant eh bien
telle et telle et telle et telle
catégorie de personnes ne seront pas
français a du fait d'une religion ou du
fait d'une origine nationale ou éthique
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait qu'on fait
la france et l'histoire de la france
c'est aussi une histoire
grâce à cet accord c'est là aussi est ce
que fier d'être français c'est juste
regarder vers le passé peut-être pas
tant la force et d'héritage dans ça et
moi je pense que je ferais revendiquer
un amour critique je pense que on peut
aimer la france tout à fait en admettant
aussi les erreurs et moi ce qui me gêne
le plus dans le débat actuel notamment
contre la prise de parole de certains
candidats et français monsieur zemmour
notamment où on vient à vouloir
idéaliser la france et à vouloir même si
un charnier qui attrape au foncé dessus
avant même le soutenir moi je suis
désolé je pense qu'on doit on doit moi
je l'admets tout à fait que la
cotisation n'était certainement pas la
même la bonne chose à faire on a fait
qu'on a fait qu'ils aient vu des crimes
etc et je pense qu'il ya une partie des
classes politiques qui refusent
d'accepter que la france n'a pas
toujours fait les bonnes décisions et
que l'état français c'est pas la france
aussi
9h15 moi moi moi j'aime mon pays je sais
où je vis jeunes lorsqu'ils pas utiles
en vue de la reconnaître les erreurs
sur le génocide rwandais excusez moi la
france encore une fois la france et est
très exemplaire là dessus allez demander
par exemple à deux pays qui eux ont
colonisé je pense par exemple vous savez
des os et des gabarits avait des peuls
condé wolof etc on leur a jamais demandé
de s'excuser
voilà je pense que la france s'adapte
docile
c'est pour ça que
notre histoire aussi fier mais moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui ce que
pensait le tiers de tous les noms mais
on peut être fier d'être français je
fais des tarifs fier d'être français de
saint céré ciblage votre cuisse dont le
passé pierre plus celles à venir soient
meilleurs nous
connaître et faire connaître l'histoire
de la france oui maintenant je sais
peut-être que le terme peut-être que le
terme idéalisé était un peu fort mais
aujourd'hui on le voit et des historiens
ont travaillé dessus il ya un petit
livre qui est paru récemment je me
souviens plus du nom mais on vous le
retrouverez certainement qui permet
justement de voir que chez certains
candidats il y a quand même des des
erreurs alors pas forcément des erreurs
sur tout ce qui est dit mais en tout cas
une manière de réécrire l'histoire en
tout cas de l'interpréter d'une certaine
manière qui la rend à un peu fausse on
pas dire complètement fausse il ya des
vérités mais il ya une main noire et qui
peut aboutir des tibétains
on le voit l'arrivée de la vague ou
ressortirait en retard cette heure
juste c'est une des thèses d'eric
zemmour cdi acsi aux critiques pète
après on peut pas les notions techniques
sont ils étaient ici est aujourd'hui le
candidat
d'un média ça fait partie des dead est
chaude il va nous rester un quart
d'heure démission parlons de la
présidentielle à proprement parler
peut-être aussi avant de relancer cette
discussion nouveau micro trottoir nous
sommes allez vous poser la question
auprès des plus jeunes bien sûr allez
vous voter pour la présidentielle pour
certains ce sera la première fois qu'ils
vont pouvoir voter à cette élection bah
ouais moi c'est sûr je vais aller voter
parce que déjà je pense que c'est un
devoir citoyen d'aller voter c'est une
manière de faire entendre ma parole et
puis je veux surtout pas laisser passer
des candidats comme zemmour le pen oui
je vais voter aux présidentielles parce
que je trouve que c'est quand même assez
grave ce qui se passe en ce moment
notamment qu'il va les réformes je pense
qu'actuellement il ya personne qui
pourrait nous représenter
je ne fais pas du tout confiance aux
partis politiques mais on essaie de
choisir le moins pire on est des femmes
et qu'il ya des femmes qui se sont
battues pour ce droit et qu' il faut
respecter ce droit et la phase aller
n'est pas très française du coup bien
sûr que oui je vais voter il ya trop de
femmes qui se sont battues pour qu'on
vote bien sûr qu'on a voté je sait pas
encore c'est pas sûr
ça dépendra des candidats on a toujours
les mêmes les mêmes discours fascisant
qui compte en temps toute la journée en
boucle et que ça ferait du bien d'avoir
d'avoir d'autres discours et que la
gauche puisse
puisse faire un peu contrepoids là
dessus c'est compliqué parce que
maintenant les gens qui font la
politique sont très controversés je sais
pas trop je n'aime pas trop la politique
je vais essayer de tas de voter
peut-être voté blanc parce que c'est un
peu compliqué en ce moment y a pas
d'adhésion envers un candidat jeu c'est
souvent dû roger qui s'expriment aussi
il faut aller voter parce que faire
barrage à un tales faire barrage à intel
plus de la moitié des moins de 30 ans
pourrait ne pas aller voter il ya aussi
les fécos vide ces jeunes qui se sont
sentis abandonnés isolés pendant leurs
études aussi notamment perte des petits
boulots aussi pour la plupart comment
vous allez les réconcilier puisqu'on l'a
compris vous êtes engagé vous avez vos
motifs mais comment les désengager pour
qu'ils aillent voter cette fois ci faire
un tour de table allez-y vous commencez
va je pense que c'est avec le travail de
base un cds a rencontré les gens c'est
défendre défendre les positions
défendues candidats après on n'est que
des militants aussi dans un monde qui
bouge avec aussi on pourrait parler
aussi de l'individualisme et autres le
la vision toujours court terme des
choses la politique à ce problème là
qu'elle vise toujours le long terme elle
vise toujours les la complexité et donc
ça me met toujours du temps à travailler
on a un travail de fourmi on est des
militants on est sur le terrain au plus
bas et donc c'est moi je crois que c'est
que c'est par le nombre qu'on peut
gagner et donc sans étant très nombreux
à faire ce petit travail là qu'on peut
réussir à mobiliser les gens ceci dit
c'est la parole après mais sur les
différents candidats chacun fait des
propositions pour les plus jeunes
étaient souvent de l'argent aussi vous
parler du long terme et on s'il cherche
quelquefois aussi court terme pour
récupérer des voix 1 parce que ce côté
très bien au sel c'est un revenu
étudiants 850 euros pour valérie
pécresse et le revenu jeune actif 670
euros pour les jeunes avec macron vous
parlais tout à l'heure de jeu du petit
livre que vous aviez recueilli des
différentes propositions c'était que
chaque jeune dispose d'un montant
minimum pour vivre dignement avec une
aide accordée aussi voilà donc on promet
de l'argent aussi aux jeunes pour les
faire voter les autres car monte en
l'air froid qui a pas de montant si si
si il ya un long temps j'allais le dire
enfin le président de la république a
actuellement à a signé un texte de loi
qui va rentrer en vigueur en mars et qui
va permettre le contrat d'engagement
pour les jeunes et qui va permettre pour
des jeunes qui auraient pu avoir le
droit à certains minimums sociaux mais
qui ne sont pas accessibles puisqu'ils
ont moins de 25 ans quand ils suivent
une formation qu'ils ont un premier job
qui leur permet pas d'avoir suffisamment
de revenus pour soi vivre eux mêmes soit
financer leur formation ne serait-ce que
les trajets du quotidien etc il ya un
revenu d'engagement qui a et qui a été
mis en place qui va être d'à peu près 5
150 euros alors c'est très certainement
pas suffisant pour répondre à toutes les
problématiques des jeunes qui sont dans
un cas de précarité mais c'est déjà une
première mesure et on le voit que
maintenant les les candidats qu'ils
soient de gauche ou de droite et ben
reprennent un peu le dispositif et
rajoute un peu d'argent par dessus parce
que bien sûr val d'oise et faire voter
les jeunes à la présidentielle y fera
uniquement là pour mettre de l'argent
alors c'est juste pour être sûr
l'argent les jeunes ils ont eu trop
l'habitude que ce soit ça a été le cas
en 2012 en 2017 ce sera le cas en 2022
on leur propose énormément de
dispositifs qui va leur donner soi
disant plus de moyens au final il voit
pas arriver grand chose ou alors
tardivement et voilà le revenu
d'engagement la rive mais il est tardive
certes pour engager les jeunes je pense
qu'il ya il ya trois moyens il ya
d'abord nous notre travail de militants
sur le terrain et je pense que c'est
celui qui a le plus d'impact puisque
c'est là on rencontre les gens et au fur
et à mesure des semaines passées sur les
affaires les mêmes marchés avec des
intervalles très réguliers ben rencontre
des gens qui au début nous disent non ça
m'intéresse pas la prendre la deuxième
fois ils prennent le tracter la
troisième ils reviennent vers nous en
effet il nous disait ce qu'on peut
discuter parce que ça et ça et c'est en
étant au contact des gens après il ya
les réseaux sociaux ça fonctionne plutôt
bien pour certains partis pour d'autres
- je pense qu'encore là il faut il faut
démystifier un peu les réseaux sociaux
on n'attire pas les jeunes avec les
réseaux sociaux vu que les réseaux
sociaux fonctionnent quand même sur des
boucles assez fermé et en fait on
adresse que des personnes qui le suivent
a déjà ou qui sont déjà dans des cercles
et on touche très peu ou en tout cas
très difficilement qu'on est des gens
beaucoup plus diverse et après je pense
qu'il ya ce travail et c'est difficile
de le faire pendant les présidentielles
mais c'est d'organiser des événements où
on participe à titre d' engager
politiquement mais à des choses
associative des ans des réunions
publiques dans les quartiers moins
politique mais où on vient échanger et à
la fin on peut parler de notre
engagement est peut-être que ça va en
dégager certains mais surtout leur
montrer que ben c'est peut-être en
s'engageant qu'on va changer leur
quotidien changer le quotidien de leur
ville je sais pas ce que c'est à dire
que donner de l'argent pour donner de
l'argent est bon en fait suffira pas il
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va faire
avancer les choses il faut aller et je
rejoins quentin là dessus s'il faut
aller rencontrer les gens faut aller
faire du porte-à-porte faut aller sur
les marchés tracter expliqué ben voilà
nouvelle proposition pour vous les
jeunes voilà etc et puis en fonction
enfin il des jeunes choisiront la villa
n'en fais pas il doit y avoir des dégâts
mais aussi à des cdd des problèmes
oeuvre depuis que moi je vous dis au
contraire sort hier soir j'étais au
plessis-robinson il y avait 350
adhérents la république d'iran
reconquête de la confiance
il y avait beaucoup de jeunes dans la
salle avait énormément de jeu et puis
j'avais des amis qui venaient de
versailles avec ical et au plessis
robinson pour rencontrer des
personnalités comme antoine diers c'est
ce ce rigolo rouste reçue et ses co
rejoint avec ces mots donc donc non nous
on y arrive on arrive à aller sur le
terrain rencontrer les jeunes on a eu
dix mille jeunes en deux mois seulement
enfin c'est du jamais vu on sur les
réseaux sociaux alors après ce réseau il
ya une professionnalisation c'est vrai
que la candidature d'eric zemmour tirer
et
sur les réseaux sociaux aussi parce que
finalement c'est là où sont les jeunes
ils sont sur les réseaux sociaux et
votre maman vous disait que en fait
c'est finalement ça ne fait pas tout
mais je comprends pas pourquoi votre
votre majorité présidentielle a mis
énormément de 2
il met des moyens là dedans passive la
vie on peut pas dire que ont tout juste
pour les plus d'accord sur pc ça fait
aussi partie des endroits où nous parler
de vos candidats
non
non je voulais juste parce que là vous
parlez on a parlé d' aider des revenus
de formation de l'as des subventions
c'est vrai la communication est très
importante dans le lit mais il ya
quelque chose qui s'est très constant
dans le temps mais il ya quelque chose
que vous avez oublié chers amis c'est
que les jeunes déjà ils sont pas bêtes
c'est pas des crétins il faut une vision
et un peuple de
vision vraie vision pour eux d'avenir et
je vous donnais un chiffre très simple
les têtes le branding qui a des france
des jeunes français vers l'étranger le
coc vide a été un accélérateur de ça
puisque ils étaient confinés première
chose qu'ils ont commencé ct kwh à
s'échapper s'échapper de leur propre
pays
rendez compte c'est donc si on donne pas
une véritable vision à nos jeunes
comment par exemple peut se former pour
moins cher comment trouver un travail
plus facilement bref avoir un avenir
dans pis ça sert à rien de faire des
réunions publiques des portes aborde
crever vont pas vous écouter l'idée
d'abord c'est d'avoir une vision une
stratégie pour eux aujourd'hui je pense
que valérie pécresse est bien parti pour
un candidat parce que vous défendez
chacun chacun un candidat je sais pas en
une minute à peu près chacun pourquoi il
faut pourquoi elle est pourquoi il faut
voter zemmour d'après moi ce qu'il faut
aider ces mots parce que zemmour est
simple ans est le seul candidat
aujourd'hui qu'ils portent réellement un
amour profond pour la france et qui
finalement veuille puiser dans les
racines de la france un avenir meilleur
aujourd'hui la france en france il ya
des professeurs qui sont décapités il ya
des prêtres qui sont assassinés en
martyrs qui sont tombés en martyrs comme
quand il prêche aujourd'hui on a des
attentes à près près enfin tous les cinq
ans aujourd'hui on a on a un pays
complètement divisé il exhume on veut
lutter contre le grand place et combler
le grand défi il aurait atteint
d'attentât y aura un combat et je pense
qu'il fera tout pour cueillir des mois
et aujourd'hui règlement ceci dit
excusez moi je vous permet de rebondir
ça voudrait dire ce que vous dites que
les autres font rien pour qu'il y en ait
moins ce que par tout un chacun
s'imagine chose est sûre je pense qu'il
va être passée au scandale mais je pense
que maintenant c'est de voir à quel que
soit le candidat président en exercice
pendant l'exercice est quelqu'un qui
fasse quelque chose pour qui on est plus
ou qu'il fasse rayonner ans après le
terme ce qu'un jour ce qui met pas tous
les moyens à disposition pour qu'il en
est aujourd'hui ben voila quand on aime
la france quand on est motivation quand
on m e notre culture est bon voter les
z'amours parce que voilà ce qu'était ce
nom avec les rivières alors nous aussi
on aimerait
surtout au sénat alors moi tu iras
landry phoenix honnêtement moi je pense
vous avez le droit de vous engager et
heureusement de continuer je pense que
pourquoi valérie pécresse et la mire des
candidates soit parce que c'est une
femme je déteste qu'on dise oui des
usines fun faut voter pour elle non pas
du tout c'est l'argument peu du nôtre
c'est juste qu'elle se présente tel quel
c'est tout c'est un symbole important
fait logique mais le plus important
c'est que je pense que techniquement on
compétences c'est le programme qui est
le plus je dirais abouti par rapport à
d'autres d'autre part au niveau de la
jeunesse que je représente aussi je
pense qu'elle a tout de suite compris
que la clé de voûte pour que les jeunes
puissent en sortir c'était la formation
et l'apprentissage à la région d'île de
france elle a été exceptionnelle rien
sur la gestion budgétaire et troisième
pont je pense que valérie c'est celle
qui rassemble plus à droite au centre
centre droit et droite et on verra au
second tour déjà pour eric zemmour je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'il ait ses
parrainages pour l'instant je n'ai pas
eu d'information là dessus
comme j'espère pour vous mais
honnêtement pour le débat n'est certes
important honnête mais ce choix c'est
une question nous engager à tous les cas
un cas presque ça serait pas ça ne
serait pas quand même une sorte de crise
démocratique s'il n'y
pas totalement
j'aimerais que eric zemmour fait parlera
par différents états majors de partis
sur le baudet réservé à certains de ces
derniers comme s'il fallait apporter
pour que chacun des candidats puissent
être à la fin sur la ligne de départ en
mars il le ferait on parle du modem qui
a annoncé que s'il fallait il apporte
une partie de ce parrainage modèle c'est
ma main gauche le sort à droite c'est
maintenant la série dramatique naufrage
des parrainages ça serait pas mal
gardé un matelas parrainage au cas où
les candidats des
cantons pourquoi il faut voter fabien
roussin qui fait une très bonne campagne
pour le coup il faut voter pour recel
parce que les jeunes aujourd'hui il
souffre du fait que les inégalités
augmentent encore une fois et donc c'est
toujours les sur les plus jeunes qui
sont bloqués dans leur avenir du coup on
leur propose la droite notamment
historiquement leur proposer des
contrats des moindres contrat parce
qu'ils aient des jeunes parce qu'ils
sont pas expérience qu'il faudrait
qu'ils soient moins payés que les autres
je pense que le roussel c'est celui qui
défend des bonnes questions travail un
bon salaire dès l'entrée dans la vie
active la possible d'avoir un logement
assez facilement la sécurité dans l'est
dans les soins la sécurité aussi pour
ses parents avant d'avoir du travail
parce que ses parents pour partir à la
retraite pas trop tard et donc pour
avoir aussi une belle retraite plus tard
c'est celle des jours heureux les jours
heureux qui font référence au programme
du cnr de la résistance après six ans de
guerre mondiale et l'on veut retrouver
sa retrouver cet esprit d'un état qui
prend soin d'une nation qui prend soin
des siens
des siens des siens de façon très large
aussi à tous ceux qui travailleront le
droit ont le droit aux mêmes droits il
n'y a pas de différence le s'appeler
mohammed n'est pas un problème dans la
france de fautes famille roussel par
exemple
et au moins on construit collectivement
construit un avenir quand yves mans un
meilleur avenir en croyant aux pouvoirs
publics aux croyants aux services
publics en croyant la force du collectif
et au fait que c'est le travail qui doit
payer et pas et pas l'héritage est pas
les héritiers comme le fait la droite et
comme on l'a vu la proposition sur les
héritages notamment m'est apparue en
détresse mais on sait qu'ils vont
hélas en voile et on voit la logique
d'intérêts et c'est important si de le
rappeler pour les jeunes on défend ses
intérêts aussi et donc c'est important
de dire aux jeunes et défendez vos
intérêts vous allez vivre par votre
travail défendez le camp du travail ne
défendez pas le camp de ceux qui
possèdent les moyens de production qui
possède qui précède le capital quand on
est riche on est déjà à habas quand on
voit les propositions de l'ump classe
par exemple c'est zemmour qui se devait
faire la grande fusion au final on sait
très bien qu est-ce qui défend au final
sciemment d'antenne économique les trois
candidats sont très très proches des
défunts de la même chose ici bas
vraiment autre chose s'ils veulent autre
chose qu avec délice nationale
l'association d'edf
les services publics partout les
hôpitaux partout oui c'est de faire que
tous les territoires lutter contre la
métropolisation en mettant des services
publics ils
exhalent tour pourquoi il faut rééditer
mes deux albums alors je n'irai pas
jusque là puisque moindre aujourd'hui et
il est pas candidat et j'ai si jamais il
était trempé en 2h04 évidemment se sont
pendant 45 minutes j'aurais dit je pense
qu'aujourd'hui si on doit s'adresser aux
jeunes dans cette élection
présidentielle et pour qu'ils puissent
trouver le candidat qui les représente
mieux je pense qu'il faut les invités à
regarder un peu ce qui s'est fait depuis
cinq ans ce qui est à la fois proposée
par les autres candidats et puis ce qui
a été réalisé depuis depuis cinq ans
depuis cinq ans il ya eu un plan qui a
été mis en place qui s'appelle le plan
un jeune une solution et qui a permis à
trois millions de jeunes de se connecter
sur la plateforme et soit d'avoir une
meilleure vision des des droits auxquels
ils avaient le droit des services qui
pouvait les accompagner dans la
recherche d'un emploi d'une formation
d'un logement d'un permis de conduire et
il ya eu quand même sept cent mille
contrats d'apprentissage sur 2000 21 ans
j'entends beaucoup de candidats parler
de l'apprentissage enfin aujourd'hui le
président de la république qui a remis
l'apprentissage au centre de la création
de travail de formation et d'un avenir
pour les jeunes c'est emmanuel macron
avec avec ce plan qui a été massif on
est passé d'à peine 300 mille contrats
d'apprentissage en 2017 à 700 milles et
même le coc vide qui aurait pu être un
frein drastiques pour les entreprises on
a vu que les entreprises au contraire
ont trouvé un élan en embauchant des
jeunes en les formant et en se disant
que alors que c'est une période
difficile en prenant un jeune en
apprentissage
elles lui permettent aussi de s'intégrer
dans l'entreprise
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron des n'est
pas candidat on espère qu'il le sera en
tout cas dans la majorité présidentielle
mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
propositions qui vont arriver pour les
jeunes celles qui ont déjà été mises en
place celle qu'on peut défendre avec les
jeunes avec macron que ce soit pour la
gratuité des protections pour toutes
dans les universités mais aussi pour les
jeunes actives jusqu'à un certain âge
parce qu'on sait que ça représentait un
coût la lutte contre certaines maladies
qui touchent notamment les femmes si on
parle de l'endométriose mais c'est aussi
peut-être une vision avant tout
l'émancipation le jeune il doit pouvoir
quel que soit son milieu d'origine par
un travail par informe par la formation
et par l'accès aussi au logement
individuel de pouvoir s'émanciper et de
trouver sa place dans la société et sa
place quelle qu'elle soit et je trouve
que pour ça l'apprentissage offre
vraiment on sort du modèle de tout
grandes écoles pour se dire eh bien il
ya une autre il ya une autre formation
possible si elle amène à un travail
juste important juste un peu juste à
voir votre réaction il ya eu le
l'entrevue entre autres
le maquereau et de l'émir poutine
petit qui dit me torturer pendant six
titres est ce que est ce que là il ya
une incarnation quand même est-ce que
vous voyez vos candidats à la place
d'emmanuel mâcon dans ce genre
d'exercice évidemment oui d'ailleurs
j'ai vu à la télé valérie qui parlaient
en russe j'ai trouvé ça incroyable
mais j'ai trouvé d'une exemplarité voilà
on voit bien qu'elle a la stature d'une
présidente keystone stature content
parce que quand on est président ça
parte un plus comme je l'aï dit on est
élu on représente la nation et donc le
pays ils peuplent les français du coup
quand j'ai vu valérie moi je pense
qu'elle va être exceptionnel dans ce
rôle là et j'ajoute qu'elle a beaucoup
d'expérience quand même aller et
ministre plusieurs fois donc je pense
que oui elle pourrait je pense pas ça
d'autres homologues à l'étranger je
pense ça sera une vraie lanières de
châtrices oui
oui j'ai dernier dans l'oural et s à
face à coude et comment elle gère
adéquat est chose acquise et
la question comment vos candidats réagir
et aussi quand on entend encore ce matin
que la dmr poutine dit la france est
hors jeu moi ce qui a été dit avec
emmanuel macron m'agresse qu'un masque a
dit emmanuel macron la france n'a rien à
voir dans la discussion et c'est ce qui
s'est passé ce matin juste avant la
phase et émissions le bras de fer qu'il
ya eu entre poutine et emmanuel macron
il a été gagné par poutine et on l'a vu
avec ce beau lui va renverser cette ce
rapport de force c'est une grande table
et je pense trimestre les grandes tables
renversées elle a l'air lourd mais aussi
sur un exercice de communication si on
reprend un peu ce qui s'est passé il ya
cinq il ya dix il ya 15 ans puisque la
demi-heure poutine était déjà au pouvoir
à ce moment là quand il était sorti de
ses entrevues que ce soit avec nicolas
sarkozy avec françois hollande sur
certaines questions il ya aussi un
aspect très russe dans le fait de dire
ce qui s'est passé ne compte pas in fine
et la décision allait de mon côté donc
entre le souvenir de la réaction de
nicolas savoye dire à la société
souvenez de la design nous disent vous
mettez pas forcément très à l'aise
c'est le match le plus doux de du monde
1 2 et d'aujourd'hui on peut le dire
s'il va guider il est très attendu
rapport de force et
sa
lamentable c'est qu'on est à on est
ultra proche d'une élection
présidentielle qu'on a encore un
candidat qui continue à jouer son rôle
présidentiel qui est
là qui fait campagne en voulons pas
mettre en allant dire je suis président
je
fermerai reprochait aussi si l'un veille
de ce départ à moscou il avait annoncé
qu'en dîtes moi candidat de la
république vous verrez je fais un
candidat à la présidence de la
république je vais négocier
régler en 24 heures avec levier et je
vais revenir et ça sera parfait non là
il joue ça il ya une stature de
président de la république et alors il
est vrai que ça peut frustrer certaines
personnes qui soient pas en confiance
aujourd'hui je mets au défi n'importe
quel candidat n'importe quel président
de la république à sa place de se dire
c'est un bon timing en pleines
négociations avec la russie et l'ukraine
d'être en même temps candidat quand on
est candidat il faut qu'on en est alors
la crise sera pas réglé dans une semaine
dans quinze jours dans trois semaines
mais au moins il fait là les rendez-vous
qui sont importants qui peuvent marquer
sipa une sortie de la crise en tout cas
une désescalade dans le conflit et je ne
suis pas sûr que s'il était en même
temps en train de courir après un
meeting où après une élection qui
pourrait le faire aussi bien président
du cias dans 10 à jour sur deux pour un
président pour européen il aurait pu
laisser le leadership à l'union
européenne pour négocier il a préféré
prendre le leadership attendait c'est
aussi
quand même en aura pas personne ne
voulait aller affronter la crise des
portes et le sujet doit passer deux ans
puisque
je vous propose c'est qu'on peut se
retrouver sa voix et le candidat sera
déclaré
l'agente au timbre officialisé on aura
l'occasion de continuer cette discussion
merci beaucoup patrice marciano quatre
invités d'être venu parler de politique
l'engagement des jeunes en politique
c'était le thème de notre émission
aujourd'hui
[Musique]